what's up hot breath diverse welcome
back to the hot breath podcast this is
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros
I am comedian Joel Byers and I had been
seeing a lot of reviews of Louis CK's
new special all over YouTube and most of
them weren't comedians so I wanted to
share my personal experience as watching
it from the comedian perspective and in
my opinion this is Louis CK's swaggy
absurdity at its best seriously look at
all that sweat and it's because he's
talking about a lot of different taboo
topics and only the way louis c.k can
get away with doing he does touch on his
scandal if you will but it's not a theme
of the show but it's rather almost like
a playful seasoning sprinkled throughout
and he really does address it in a way
that I think everyone can leave the
special with his perspective on it but
also without leaning on it too much
because he covers a lot of different
topics and I think it's so important for
every comedian to watch this special
just to not only gain perspective into
well not only his timing in terms of
just flawless comedic timing but also
his ability to commit to a bit and to
navigate a bit and there's moments where
he sets up the audience to then call out
their hypocrisy but a lot of comics try
to touch on the more taboo topics but
they just don't have the skill set yet
Louie CK is at the top of the food chain
when it comes to stand-up comedy and he
proves that in this special so when you
do order this special which it is
available on his website which wow a
comedian didn't release a special out on
a streaming platform but released it
straight to consumer from their website
like all the great
comics do my comedy special the trophy
husband is currently available on my
website Joel buyers Comedy dot-com for
those of you to purchase shameless plug
but that'll be linked in the description
as well but the whole point of this
review is just to say give it a shot go
to his website give it a view you're in
for some good laughs but also just and
there's a lot of comedy out there but
there is only one louis c.k and he
proves it with this special sincerely so
please if you do find this review
helpful just subscribe to the show we're
gonna be here releasing weekly videos
all around the topic of comedy education
so check out our other reviews and our
other playlists and we'll see in the
next video